make way for Josh Duhamel we wanted to
have a big big opening here big
presentation the doors are open and Josh
Duhamel is now entering the building
yeah there he is oh yeah backwards
[Applause]
Josh Duhamel yes
hat backwards shoes no I have your back
I got my phone I got my wallet oh you do
yeah did you just wake up I did I did I
had a late night last night karaoke hard
where'd you where'd you go I was down at
Koreatown and what's your go-to song
[Laughter]
there's not a big call for todo no no
but it's an amazing song no it's not I
test my voice a little oh oh dude yeah
yeah yeah so we're glad to have you I
didn't know you were karaoke I didn't
know you had talents I don't usually
what you drink last night a lot of
tequila it's okay we're glad to have you
so your final four you got Arizona North
Carolina West Virginia Duke Arizona
beating Duke and the title game yeah
do you remember filling out the bracket
I do okay I do I do and you think I had
to call and ask if I could be part of it
this year it's like I feel like I'm
being sort of broken up is that true
yeah Fritzie is that true yeah that's
not true
here's Josh did not realize he didn't
have the security and himself to know
that your inner circle you was on the
way to you oh really
you jumped the gun was on the way yeah I
owe the Hollywood Life no let's don't
call us we'll call you
you've had that before right we've had
those meetings where the date they say
they'll call you oh yeah Bailey what is
it give me the biggest you know biggest
movie you auditioned for
and you didn't get it the biggest one I
auditioned for was uh was it John Carter
of Mars John that movie it didn't do so
well so it's not you did more broken
because I thought I was gonna get it
yeah and it was you know it turned out
to not do so well so sometimes you know
but what is that like when you go in and
like you put your heart in front of
somebody that's part of the game man you
gotta you know have a really thick skin
because you get rejected a lot more than
you get accepted in this but how do you
get rejected how do they tell you have
you ever been told right to your face
like it no you got no shame you got no
shot yeah I mean normally you just don't
get the call you got a call so it's like
you see there you know if they'll come
up with a nice reason why it's usually
like well you know you're too young
you're too old you're too tall was one
yeah okay is there you sucked is their
height ISM in in Hollywood yeah I think
so because most of the the women are you
know you have to have the same height
and not really it's not as big a deal as
you might think they have little apple
boxes that but Vince Vaughn is is a tall
guy older than me five or six so he's
done pretty well yeah but it feels like
you have to be a little shorter like Tom
Cruise like a jockey yeah yeah it's like
five you can't be over six feet tall yes
you can
there's a lot of people that are there
playing okay I was trying to look at you
you're what six - yeah it's 6-3 6-3 in
the movie is Sandler so it's not like
I'm auditioning yeah well you told me
you're gonna do my movie and I just they
said I would help you
I will voice that for you won't yes but
you have to give it to me I did didn't I
send it to you you didn't give me the
copy you sent me your home I sent you my
version but I thought you guys are gonna
take my version and rework it and send
me okay paulie's they all no no he sends
me the opening of
movie and then he said yeah I want you
to voice it I said okay he doesn't send
me the copy I will I will do that today
okay and then all and then I'll voice it
for you okay and then you can you know
I'll give you a little little smoke on
it I'll give you a little bit of that
down here amazing what happens if this
is very apropos what happens if you do
it we don't use it would you be hurt no
you wouldn't know like if you get Morgan
Freeman
then then fine no unless you get even
Seagal or some the only reason we would
I don't want to say this because I'd
really love for you to do it okay but
there's a there's a vo at the end you
might have to do a vo at the beginning
and at the end just did like tie the
whole thing yeah I can do that okay yeah
look at that he's already getting smoky
yeah yeah this is gonna crush do they
give an Academy Award for voice over in
all of each they do not know okay
in a world but I'll do it for you I
would love that Dan and I mean that no
but I said I would do it just send me
the copy okay and I promise done today
um do you want to explain your bracket
philosophy or strategy you know I don't
know much about what's going on this
year I saw few of the games I have
Oklahoma losing first round to Rhode
Island yeah my Rams uh I have South
Dakota State beating somebody in the
first round
right that's just kind of an upset I
picked a few upsets but I don't I don't
know there's usually a five the beats of
12 right yeah toilet it beats of fun or
earthed I'm sorry have you and I just
felt like you know Arizona's got a chip
on their shoulder they got two amazing
players I forget the names treant rayon
and eight and what's the guy's name is
gonna go number one eight eight yeah
yeah he's really good yeah he might be
the best player in the term yeah it's
right here
did you have a favorite player growing
up
yes I did I love Johnny number Johnny
Dawkins yeah I loved watching him play
Duke yeah yeah
he was one of their first stars when you
thinking like Danny Ferry was probably
of that era with Coach K but pre
Laettner Johnny Dawkins
I thought Johnny Dawkins was that
athlete that you didn't expect to go to
Duke and there that and then all of a
sudden you were like in a Tommy a marker
and you know the coach Coach K and then
all of a sudden he went to the one in
Dunn's so he got these kids to stay
I like that Coach Calipari said you know
it was it wasn't cool you know
recruiting one and done until Coach K
did it right yeah which can do no wrong
yeah but you know Calipari head of the
game with the one in Dunn's Coach K does
it then all of a sudden people go bleh
that's a smart coach you know you think
they're gonna do are they gonna continue
that are they gonna go back to just you
don't have to go at all or they stay two
years well the NBA is the one that holds
all the cards it's not college
basketball I think it hurts college
basketball isn't it the one and done
yeah no I'd rather have you for one than
none why'd rather have you for two than
one yeah but then I'm being greedy but I
these kids should be able to decide if
if that's what their future is and they
want to try and if it doesn't work then
you know should they be able to come
back into college that it doesn't work
that I think should be open that should
be on the table depending on whether or
not they got drafted worthy yes yes
we're talking to Josh Duhamel
he's let's see um you want a Daytime
Emmy I did I did for soap opera stuff
yeah really yeah All My Children was
this one you dyes second year no no this
is the year before that
he said hard worked to be on a soap
opera yeah
it's incredibly it's like boot camp for
actors really I had I had no experience
going in you know for me learning how to
you know hit my mark learn my lines all
that stuff is like day in day out and
it's like you know you sinker you swim
what was your character's name leo
Dupree did you pray don't change to do
pray well the guy that I play opposite
of now on an unsolved yeah he's darin
Dupree and I played Leo Duprey okay
bu PR es he was French that's kind of
like I was like Eurotrash but you came
in it I came in leather pants and a
mohair sweater did you have an accent no
I told you I was very new okay but you
would have an accent now if you did
probably yeah what was the guy used to
do later in the in the was that accent
Ricardo Montalban yes it would have been
Ricardo montalban's okay fine Corinthian
leather why must she love me so much
yeah what is that accent by the way
where is he from where where's Ricardo
Montalban from checking oh I have no I
have no idea
uh you're you're all happy with Kirk D
cousins right I'm uh I have mixed
feelings about it he's obviously a good
quarterback good solid quarterback but I
thought case was a good solid
quarterback too and what I liked about
what case did this year was he won games
in the clutch and he he pushed he he
pushed the ball downfield
you're not sold on this yeah I'm not
well I mean I'm not against it either I
think that he could be really good I
just didn't see him win a lot of big
games in the clutch when they could have
I'm happy for him okay I'm now I'm for
us I think it's I think it's I think
it's gonna be all right Paulie where's
who Ricardo Montalban he's from Mexico
do so don't make secure some Mexico okay
they're so weak so what do you guys
think about the Kirk Cousins move you
like it yeah I mean that's kind of it's
like I think so I could do really well a
lot of guaranteed money and I'm not
against these guys getting their money
yeah I I want to see how he you know in
a functional organization but he's gonna
have a lot more pressure on it yeah
that's for sure
that's what I want to see if he's able
to handle that I think you will I think
you'll be able yet McLovin do you want
to break this down for Josh I'm kind of
with Josh but I you know how I feel like
what was wrong with Case Keenum that's
what I kind of get back they were 13 and
3 last year so it's a lot of pressure on
cousins hmm but dad said this like three
weeks ago he said watch out for Kirk
Cousins the Vikings as before was
anywhere I was like they're not gonna
spend all that money how do you pay all
the defense there and answer me that
answer me I used to pay all those stars
in two years well that's the problem is
you start spending that much on one guy
hurts the rest the team yes
you know Zimmer asked me to go to the QB
rookie camp this year why why because he
wants me to have a shot to play for the
Vikings
wait so Mike Zimmer asked you to go he
did he thinks it'd be fun and gos said I
don't want anything that Hollywood
you're gonna come you're gonna go to
meetings you give me the whole thing
what can I drink beer at lunch he's like
alright I'll let you do that are you are
you gonna do it you think I'm gonna do
it why wouldn't you bring can you bring
a film crew with you uh I don't know
maybe he's a good idea yeah Josh goes to
camp that would be so much fun
we'll produce it do you think I'm gonna
get hazed yes I should do have to shower
with those guys would be really Josh
Duhamel stars and soft knocks limp limp
knocks is what do we have an item we
have a major Josh Duhamel related item
for next let's go to point if you want
to put do you have headphones to put on
there behind you Josh so Paul you have
an eye team report on Josh yeah our
buddy Josh Duhamel said he went out
singing karaoke last night your song was
Africa by toto mm-hmm you sing the
course again for me Josh
I bless the waves down in Africa the
it's I bless the rain what is I test the
waves down it just the waves I bless the
rain that was that was the big for us
that's big news that's how it could have
been a lot worse
I didn't know you believed me what's
great to see is always good to see you
got you in the bracket John did you
solve the the Tupac and Biggie we know
we take a break I want to in all
seriousness ask you about this yeah
because I know
important that you know for you it's
called unsolved you play a detective and
unsolved the murders of Tupac and
notorious b.i.g
alright we'll take a break Josh Duhamel
will stay with us
continuing with Josh Duhamel the actor a
big Minnesota Viking fan and of course
he won an Emmy he plays a detective and
unsolved the murders of Tupac and
notorious b.i.g anon USA when do we find
out who killed Tupac and Biggie you find
out in this I mean we what we do is we
lay out all these facts you get you you
see what actually happened and the
problem the show is called unsolved but
it's not as if they don't know what
happened
solving this case would have taken a
monumentous sort of you know feat just
to get all the testimony to get you know
both of the killers are dead and it
would have cost a lot of money so
there's well so there were two different
there are two people that there were two
investigations the original one in 1996
and then the one that my character came
on Greg Kading started the second
investigation in 2006 okay after
Biggie's mother sued the LAPD for 400
million so I brought together this task
force with ATF FBI sheriff's departments
and in other areas just to give as
unbiased opinion about what actually
happened as possible will we ever like
is there any conclusion to this yeah I
mean there's confessions but what
happened was after we concluded that the
LAPD wasn't involved in the actual
murder they didn't have anything they
were off the hook for four million so it
was crushing for for Kading and his
whole team to have to go they've worked
for three three I think for almost four
years trying to figure out what actually
happened and then they just kind of got
everything pulled out from underneath
them once they were free of any
liability I know people wanted it solved
but then you've gotten very little
cooperation from people who were around
it or knew something and then you're
worried about retribution yeah gangs
involved in this unless part of the
problem is you have
you get you have we had there there are
confessions but how much of this stuff
can you trust nobody wants to rat
anybody out because you might end up
dead there was a lot of gang activity at
the time that that you know even now
people don't want to talk well I was
curious if they see you in this role if
somebody's come up to you and given you
information or told you something that
no no not since then I mean that may
happen soon the show just started airing
a couple weeks ago but we cating is 95%
sure on one of the murders and a hundred
percent sure on the other which is
pretty good it's not what you know it's
what you can prove and then they know
it's just how do you prove it with so
many people who don't want to talk no
it's an interesting concept but have you
seen it yeah he's gonna show you no I
just saw the trailer for it it's really
good Anthony Hemingway did an amazing
job it has that feel of remember oj the
people vs. oj yeah i thought i knew
everything there was to know about that
case i skipped class in college to watch
that and there's a different it's a
different perspective on it you know
it's sort of pulling back the curtains
and seeing you know how these deaths
affected their families how they it
affected the detectives trying to bring
justice to the families yeah and Tupac
and Biggie as humans not just hip-hop
icons who were friends first
did you see the oj if i did it you know
the the Lost Tapes the interview that
Fox had last weekend no I have not seen
them yeah I mean it's Oh Jay basically
confessing really yeah I mean it's but
he says that achill yeah but he
certainly knew how he would have done it
that way but he walks you through it and
then at one point I think he says yeah
always has that creepy laugh and and
then he he talks about being with
somebody named Charlie now charlie is
involved in it did that you know there
was somebody else who was involved in
this as well but it he I remember
interviewing him when was that Paulie I
interviewed oj o 203 around there so I'm
in Florida Miami and I have this
brilliant idea let me interview oj and
talk college football with him because
he's still one of the great football
players of vault
yeah I thought maybe I could do an
interview with him and talk about you
know USC and memories and I I got there
and I realized it was just a horrible
idea cuz nobody cared they all thought
that he did this so I sit down with him
and he wanted me to know that he didn't
do this and there was this awkward
moment yeah cuz we're talking college
football I I'm talking memories and and
with a we did like a 30 minute interview
and then we changed tapes so the
cameraman goes alright stop so I'm about
four feet away from him and we're
waiting for the cameraman to put another
tape in and there's silence and then he
goes you think I did it then I go creepy
yes
and then my cameraman said alright we're
ready to roll I actually said did what
you said yes I said yes I said he did
what who his question I said he said do
you think I did it I said did what cuz I
wanted him to say it that and he said
killed those two people and I said yes
and what was his reaction he didn't say
anything
the cameraman so ready to roll and then
he wanted to try to convince me that he
didn't do this but I my body language is
so bad because I'm leaning back in my
chair as far as I can go as if he's
gonna stab me yeah during the interview
like I but to be that close to him first
of all what struck me is he he was not
an imposing figure he looked frail he
looked like many years ago is this
except 15 years ago 16 maybe but yeah to
be there and then he's telling me all
these crazy stories and I have no idea
what his life is like and I walk by a
room in Vegas and they're doing a porno
and then they want me to come in they'll
pay me three million dollars like he
just started telling me like crazy stuff
and then I realized I should have I I
should have followed up but I told him I
wasn't gonna be talking about this you
know that I was only gonna talk football
so I was trying to be fair to him and my
camera crew when he came in they said
look we're not shaking his hand I said
you don't shake his hand I have to
because I invited him for that interview
and that's one of the hardest things
ever when you have somebody come
who in your mind killed these two
innocent people and I'm shaking his hand
and I hated myself because I I I set
this up and I we never aired it but I
never heard the interview no because it
was just about Colin nobody cared about
it and I came back and I went I I don't
even know what I have here but the best
stuff was and then all this best stuff
was off caught on camera and then we got
done with the interview we did over an
hour and we got done and then he he kept
trying to convince me that he didn't
kill these people and I just didn't know
what to say and it turns out my
cameraman had been on a shoot with him
in Mexico on a movie or a TV show and he
had this knife of his that he was so
proud of and it was similar to the knife
you know that they thought committed
these crimes because they didn't find
his clothes and you know the murder
weapon and you know this cameraman said
look I I'm doing this job I don't want
any part of this with him personally and
I said you don't have to say hello
you'll have to shake his hand or
anything and he said we were in Mexico
with him and he was fascinated with this
like a green beret a Navy SEAL knife
like he was fascinated with this duck
Josh Duhamel would play that cheery
little detour there nice little segways
fast enough those Vikings how about
those about those Vikings I saw you on
Ellen after Fergie's anthem thing how
tough was that like and I know that you
went over you took flowers of like the
reaction of that how tough was that the
whole experience there it was I was on
my way back from the airport when I
heard of a friend of mine I was like uh
sorry about the the anthon I was they
were talking about and they said that it
didn't go so well so I saw when I got
home I felt I mean I've seen the girls
sing it several times Daytona 500
Patriots Dolphins home opener and she
crushes the song so I was surprised to
see that she tried what she did you know
but you know more than that it was just
it was me I just felt bad for just to
get you know those there's an army of
trolls out there who are just ready to
pounce and they were not nice
and for that I feel bad but she's a
really tough girl you know it's not easy
it's somebody you care about kid getting
hammered like that is it's not easy and
you can't and I wanted to defend her too
I wanted to go I wanted to pull the
tapes off from Daytona 500 look at this
she's really good at singing his song
but I gotta just stay out of this but
whatever it's like you want to go door
to door and yeah would you say about
Fergie yeah boom you know it's that
protective thing in you but she's uh
she's doing great
but then you you bring flowers over
mm-hmm how was it so I don't know what
else to do I was like yeah just want you
to know I got your back girl I'm with
you I'm on your side did she but then
you went on Ellen I did go on Ellen
where you talk did they bring you on to
talk about that
I didn't know they were going to just
like I didn't know we were gonna talk
about it today are we done talking about
that
I mean I have no problem talking about
it okay girls amazingly talented yeah
she really truly is and by the way her
album is amazing and you know she said
she's had a challenging year but she is
resilient would you sing the anthem if
asked um no you would not know nobody
like the Vikings would ask you see this
is what I do if I'm Mike Zimmer he's
inviting you to quarterback mm-hmm
I would have I would make you stand up
and sing the anthem you would at the at
quarterback yeah why just I'm there to
win a job he's you oh oh you get hazed
no okay so is this official that Mike
Zimmer invited you to quarterback yeah I
don't know if you had a little too much
whiskey or something the night before
but he did but it recently said are you
gonna come to you gonna come to camp and
I was like you really meant that don't
go do it cuz I gotta get I gotta get my
arm how old are you 45 so this is what
Brady's looking at right now right if he
sees you are you better than Sam
Bradford right now no I just
am i more durable than Sam Bradford
probably Brady is gonna look at you and
say that's what I'm gonna look like when
I'm 40 Brady is gonna look to me and be
I could be that Yeah right but is this
like a mini camp this is either the
rookie mitts more fun than anything yeah
yeah he asked me to do it no it's pretty
whole that's a man I want to see the new
facility first of all yeah
the new practice facility yeah and so
that's good I mean if Hubert Lee means
I'll go do that be awesome yeah McLovin
are there any rookies in their camp
because they have cousins I just traded
for Trevor Simeon
yeah is this gonna be just you I don't
know I don't know yeah so what if you're
like running the first team practice run
in first team snaps with him yeah Pauly
Josh would you retire from acting if
Mike Zimmer offers you a two-year
contract to be a third string
quarterback for two years I would retire
from acting yes yeah what if you could
never act again but you would be a
Viking third string core you would be on
the practice squad of the Vikings no you
would not do no I enjoy my job too much
how about you get to be a holder during
games on extra points what I quit my
career as an actor yeah
yes okay okay this breaking news here
great I could do that I did that in
college by the way you were the whole
guys very good oh wait now he's doing if
you're watching on audience Channel 239
DirecTV Josh just got down and it was
good really good placeholder food yeah
we did have him throw footballs here one
time
yeah bout 55 yards ahead of Matt that's
pretty good yeah you had a decent gun
and you did send your highlights to me
at one time right I'm always trying to
push myself no but that was great that
was I was impressed neither one of those
were very good by the way yeah you put
you through it you did yeah add my
Vikings
you know I remember and your sweatpants
on - I did I did
this show is on TV I didn't realize that
I was just coming here to do radio no
then you show up and you're like Chrissy
you got sweats no underwear on and
you're you're throwing the football in
the parking lot yeah all right so Josh
Duhamel you can see him in unsolved the
murders of two panca notorious b.i.g on
USA thanks for coming by thanks for
having me for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]